with businesses looking for rapid growth
with the help of data the use of data
science and organizations is playing a
crucial role data science techniques are
widely used to analyze visualize and
manipulate business data and draw
conclusions data science is a
combination of several disciplines such
as statistics visualization machine
learning and domain knowledge disease
prediction in health care customer
insights and e-commerce and fraud
detection in banking all these sectors
use data science and analytics to get
valuable insights so if you are
interested in learning data science and
its crucial techniques then we are here
to help you with that
get ready to start your data science
career with us simply learn skill up
course on data science with python will
give you all the necessary skills and
experience to become a data scientist
the best part is you can take up this
course for free that's right you can
begin your data science learning journey
with us free of cost and get a course
completion certificate for the same
simply learns data science with python
course on scale up is developed by
experienced professionals and trainers
and can be taken by anyone who aspires
to become a data scientist this course
will help you learn top skills such as
python programming data wrangling data
visualization statistics numpy scipy as
well as natural language processing the
total duration of this free data science
with python course is 8 hours and all
the modules are self-paced video lessons
with 90 days of access to the course
this allows you to learn at your own
pace and schedule after completing the
course you will receive a course
completion certificate by simply loan
this certificate can be highlighted in
your resume to increase profile
visibility and enhance the chances of
getting hired isn't that great
there is no prerequisite or eligibility
criteria to enroll in this course
however an understanding of basic python
programming and statistics would be
highly beneficial according to glassdoor
the average annual salary of a data
scientist in the united states is over
hundred thousand dollars so what are you
waiting for head straight to our scale
up page and enroll in our free data
science with python course today sign up
now and get certified with simply loan
the link is in the description box
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here